THE WHITE HOUSE.
CNN POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT,
SARA MURRAY, HAS DETAILS.
>> A TEAM HIRED BY DONALD TRUMP
'S LAWYERS, UNCOVERING TWO
ITEMS OF CLASSIFIED MARKINGS IN
A STORAGE UNIT IN WEST PALM
BEACH, A SOURCE TELLS CNN.
>> IT WILL PROVIDE THE FEDS
WITH THE ABILITY TO GO TO A
COURT AND SAY, WE NEED ANOTHER
SEARCH WARRANT.
LET US SEARCH BEDMINSTER AND
ALL THE OTHER PROPERTIES.
>> THOSE ITEMS WERE IMMEDIATELY
TURNED OVER TO THE FBI, THE
SOURCE SAYS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS HAD
CONCERNS TRUMP IS HOLDING ON TO
SENSITIVE GOVERNMENT RECORDS
SINCE FINDING DOCUMENTS MARKED
CLASSIFIED AT MAR-A-LAGO IN
AUGUST.
>> IT'S NOT A CRIME AND THEY
SHOULD GIVE ME IMMEDIATELY BACK
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN
FROM ME BECAUSE IT IS MINE.
>> TRUMP'S LAWYERS, RECENTLY
HIRING A TEAM TO SEARCH TRUMP
TOWER, THE BEDMINSTER GOLF CLUB,
A FLORIDA OFFICE, AND A STORAGE
UNIT, SOURCES TELL CNN.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, UNDER
PRESSURE FROM AN EVER GROWING
PILE OF LEGAL PROBLEMS.
NOT ONLY THE FEDERAL PROBE INTO
HIS HANDLING OF GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS --
>> THIS IS A NEW HOAX, THE
DOCUMENT HOAX.
>> BUT ALSO A SPRAWLING PROBE
INTO EFFORTS TO SUBVERT THE
2020 ELECTION.
>> WE ARE GOING TO WALK DOWN TO
THE CAPITOL.
>> THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
2020 ELECTION, ALSO MOVING
AHEAD WITH MORE GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY FROM FORMER TRUMP
ADVISOR, STEPHEN MILLER.
>> SIMPLE PRINCIPLE.
ONE CITIZEN, ONE VOTE.
>> AND SPECIAL COUNSEL, JACK
SMITH, FIRING OFF A FRESH ROUND
OF SUBPOENAS TO COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS IN WISCONSIN,
MICHIGAN, AND ARIZONA.
INVESTIGATORS SEEKING MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS FROM TRUMP AND
HIS ALLIES, SUCH AS RUDY
GIULIANI AND SIDNEY POWELL,
WITH BATTLEGROUND STATE
OFFICIALS.
ADDING TO TRUMP'S HEADACHES --
>> WE HAVE MADE DECISIONS THAT
CRIMINAL REFERRALS WILL HAPPEN.
>> SOURCES TELL CNN, THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6TH ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL WING CRIMINAL REFERRALS
FOR TRUMP AND A NUMBER OF HIS
CLOSEST ALLIES.
>> THE FACT THAT SUPPORT IT
POTENTIAL CHARGE AGAINST THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND, YOU KNOW,
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, IN MY
VIEW, NEEDS TO HOLD, YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE EQUALLY RESPONSIBLE
BEFORE THE LONG.
>> AND ALL OF THIS COMES AFTER
TWO TRUMP ORGANIZATION
COMPANIES WERE CONVICTED JUST
THIS WEEK ON MULTIPLE CHARGES
OF CRIMINAL TAX FRAUD,
FALSIFYING BUSINESS RECORDS,
AND --
TELLING CNN EARLIER THIS
MORNING THAT THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE TRUMP COMPANY'S
CONTINUES.
WOLF?
>> CERTAINLY DOES.
ALL RIGHT, SARA MURRAY
REPORTING FOR US, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LET'S BRING ALL OF THIS DOWN
WITH CNN SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT,
JAMIE GANGEL.
CNN SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST, ELIE
HONIG, AND SENIOR LEGAL
ANALYST.
MAGGIE HABERMAN.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
FOR THE NEW YORK TIMES AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLING BOOK,
CONFIDENCE MAN, THE MAKING OF
DONALD TRUMP AND THE BREAKING
OF AMERICA.
MAGGIE, YOU ALSO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT REPORTING RIGHT NOW
IN THE ADDITIONAL CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE FOUND.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> SO WOLF, THESE DOCUMENTS,
THESE ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTS,
WERE FOUND IN A SEALED BOX IN
THIS STORAGE UNIT THAT EXISTS
IN WEST PALM BEACH ABOUT 15
MINUTES OR SO AWAY FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
AND THE TRUMP FOLKS LEAD THE
DOJ KNOW THAT THEY HAVE FOUND
THIS, AS WE UNDERSTAND IT,
THERE WAS SOME KIND OF
NOTIFICATION.
WHETHER THAT IS GOING TO
SATISFY THE DOJ THAT THIS IS
EVERYTHING IS REALLY UNCLEAR,
YOU KNOW?
THEY SUPPOSEDLY SEARCHED THREE
OTHER AREAS AS WELL AND FOUND
NOTHING.
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT THINGS
KEEP TURNING UP IN VARIOUS
PLACES, I THINK THAT THE BALL
IS GOING TO BE IN DOJ'S COURT
NOW TO TRY TO DECIDE WHETHER
TAKING THEIR WORD FOR IT IS
ENOUGH FOR WHETHER TO SEARCH
AGAIN, OR TO FIND SOME OTHER
MEASURE TO GET PEOPLE TO SWEAR
THAT THIS IS EVERYTHING.
>> AND ALI, AS YOU KNOW, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAS HAD PLENTY
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO HAND OVER
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
HOW BAD IS IT THAT THEY FOUND
MORE CLASSIFIED MATERIAL AFTER
ALL OF THIS?
>> WELL, WOLF, IT'S TRULY
MIND-BOGGLING THAT EVEN AFTER
ALL THE CHANCES DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN GIVEN, HE STILL HAS
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN HIS
POSSESSION.
JUST GOING BACK THROUGH THE
TIMELINE OF THIS CASE, EVEN
THOUGH DOJ AND ARCHIVES SPENT
MONTHS UPON MONTHS POLITELY
NEGOTIATING WITH TRUMP'S TEAM,
EVEN THOUGH DOJ TRIED THE EASY
WAY WITH A SUBPOENA, REQUIRING
TRUMP TO TURN OVER ALL THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
EVEN THOUGH TRUMP'S LAWYERS
REPRESENTED TO DOJ, WE'VE NOW
GIVEN YOU ALL THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, EVEN AFTER DOJ
EXECUTED A SEARCH WARRANT AT
MAR-A-LAGO, IT TURNS OUT
THERE'S STILL AT LEAST TWO MORE
DOCUMENTS THAT TRUMP'S TEAM WAS
HOLDING.
AND TO MAGGIE'S POINT, THE OG
HAS A DIFFICULT POSITION TO
MAKE.
HERE ARE WE SATISFIED AFTER ALL
THE MISREPRESENTATIONS?
OR ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE
EVEN MORE DRASTIC MEASURES AND
PERHAPS EXECUTE A SEARCH
WARRANT AT OTHER PROPERTIES?
>> AND JAMIE, AMIDST ALL OF
THIS, THERE'S ALSO THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO JANUARY
6TH.
TODAY, THE SELECT COMMITTEE
MEMBER, AND WISH, IF AS WE JUST
HEARD, WAS ASKED AN NPR IF HE
BELIEVES IF TRUMP COMMITTED
CRIMES THAT COULD BE
PROSECUTED.
AND HE SAID, AND I'M QUOTING
HIM NOW, YES, I DO.
SO WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> THE COMMITTEE IS NOT BEING
SHY, WOLF.
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO BE ON
THAT CRIMINAL REFERRAL LIST.
ONE OF MY SOURCES SAID FRONT
AND CENTER, THE REAL QUESTION
IS, WHO ELSE IS GOING TO BE ON
THAT LIST?
WE KNOW WE HAVE NAMES YET, WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY.
BUT A SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK TOLD ME THAT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE SOME
WIDE RANGING LIST, THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE VERY
DELIBERATE.
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE
REFERRALS FOR PEOPLE ABOUT
CRIMES THAT THEY THINK THEY
REALLY HAVE STRONG, SUBSTANTIVE
EVIDENCE TO HAND OVER TO DOJ,
WOLF.
>> AND ELIE, IF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ULTIMATELY DECIDES
TO CRIMINALLY CHARGE TRUMP,
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE POSSIBLE
CHARGE OR CHARGES OF THAT
MATTER ON WHAT SORT OF TIMELINE
CAN WE ANTICIPATE?
>> WELL WOLF, LET'S REMEMBER,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
HERE WE HAVE MAR-A-LAGO AND I
THINK IN THAT CASE, WE'RE
LOOKING AT VARIOUS STATUTES
RELATING TO MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND
OTHER SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS.
ALSO, POTENTIALLY OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE FOR MISLEADING
INVESTIGATORS ABOUT WHETHER
THEY STILL HAD CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, AS WE JUST
DISCUSSED.
WHEN IT COMES TO JANUARY SIX, I
THINK IF I HAD TO FORECAST WHAT
WILL LIKELY BE IN THE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS, THAT JAMIE JUST
SPOKE ABOUT, I THINK THEY WILL
BE FOCUSING ON OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS, THE EFFORT TO TRY TO
BLOCK CONGRESS FROM COUNTING UP
THE COUNTS, THE ELECTORAL VOTES,
AND A CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE
UNITED STATES OF A FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION.
AND ONE OF THE POINTS, TO
JAMIE'S POINT, IT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE WHETHER THE
COMMITTEE SPECIFIES SPECIFIC
CRIMINAL LAWS THAT THEY SAY MAY
BE IMPLICATED HERE.
>> AND MAGGIE, WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING FROM INSIDE TRUMP'S
ORBIT?
YOU'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
REPORTING ON THIS, AS THESE
MULTIPLE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS HEAT UP.
>> WOLF, THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERN IN PARTICULAR ABOUT THE
REFERRALS THAT MIGHT BE COMING
FROM THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE.
THERE'S A LOT OF WONDERING
AMONG TRUMP'S AIDES, WHO MIGHT
THERE BE?
IS THIS JUST GOING TO BE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS?
WILL THERE BE STAFF INVOLVED?
WILL THERE BE THREATS TO TRUMP
ADVISERS?
THIS IS A CRUSH OF, YOU KNOW,
VARIOUS LEGAL THREATS THAT MOST
AIDES ARE WORRIED NOT JUST THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO IMPACT DONALD
TRUMP HIMSELF AND HIS CANDIDACY,
MANY OF THEM ARE WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THEM.
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
GOTTEN SWEPT UP IN THIS WHEN
THEY DIDN'T REALLY DESERVE IT
OR WHETHER, YOU KNOW, THEY HAD
TRIED TO GO ALONG WITH
SOMETHING THAT DONALD TRUMP
WANTED AND THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE BECOME TARGETS.
SO THAT IS A BIG SOURCE OF
CONCERN.
>> HUGE SOURCE OF CONCERN,
INDEED.
YOU KNOW, JAMIE, LIKE MAGGIE,
EVEN DOING AMAZING REPORTING ON
ALL OF THIS.
WHAT ARE THESE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS MEAN FOR THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND A
POSSIBLE INDICTMENT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW YET.
OBVIOUSLY, WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO DO.
BUT I THINK THE FACT THAT THEY
FOUND THESE TWO CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING, SORT OF COVERING
THIS FROM THE BEGINNING, WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THERE WERE
MORE THAN TWO THINGS STILL
MISSING FROM WHAT THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES EXPECTED TO GET.
SO, YOU KNOW, JUST BECAUSE THEY
FOUND TWO MORE THINGS, YOU KNOW,
JUST AS MAGGIE SAID AND ALI
SAID, MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THEY BELIEVE THERE IS MORE OUT
THERE.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE, AS
ELIE SAID, THE NEXT DECISION.
>> YEAH WOLF AND I THINK WHEN
IT COMES TO A CRIMINAL REFERRAL,
IF YOU ARE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, I THINK THIS COULD
CUT EITHER WAY IF YOU RECEIVE A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
ON THE ONE HAND, THE MORE
PEOPLE, THE MORE AUTHORITATIVE
VOICES YOU SAY, HEY, THERE IS
EVIDENCE OF WHICH DONALD TRUMP
SHOULD BE CHARGED CRIMINALLY,
YOU START TO GET THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC USED TO THIS IDEA, WHICH
IS A FOREIGN CONCEPT TO US.
WE'VE NEVER HAD A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO'S BEEN INDICTED
AND I THINK THERE ARE SOME
CONSIDERATION ON THAT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT DOES MAKE
AN INDICTMENT LOOK, IN SOME
SENSE, POLITICAL.
IT WILL ALLOW DONALD TRUMP TO
SAY, WELL, LOOK AT.
THAT CONGRESS RECOMMENDED AND
DIAMOND AND THE DOJ JUMPED
EXACTLY AS CONGRESS SAID.
SO THERE IS AN INTERESTING
POLITICAL DYNAMIC IN PLAY HERE.
ULTIMATELY, DOJ WILL REALLY
WANT THE EVIDENCE AND I